i'm here with famous author Jeffrey
Moore what are we going to do now well
continuing our exercise in the writing
curriculum we're going to focus in on
the step of invention which is when a
writer figures out what is it I have to
say and how am I going to get it said
and so what what is what do we see this
big block of text for well so one of the
things you do in a college a lot is you
read other people's writings and then
you're expected to develop your own
point of view about them so not just
read and memorize and regurgitate but
read criticize and then and then present
your own point of view so I'm going to
show you how we actually would do that
in a typical writing assignment in any
frankly any college class I've picked a
text about teaching because it's
something that you and I both care about
and it'd be like a class we might be
taking an education so I think what we'd
like to do here is have you read it out
loud and then I'm going to start to ask
you as you're going along to note your
reactions and we'll note them down and
that's the first step in the invention
process that we call read and react okay
so did I start yeah please all right so
this is the title is excerpts from high
school teacher Gerald contes resignation
already defined this oh yeah so this was
on the internet a couple of weeks ago
this is where the were in April of 2013
here and basically it's a wonderful high
school teacher who fundamentally had
just had enough and in resigning he sort
of laid out what what his feelings were
and they resonate got a lot of got a lot
of circulation on the internet okay so
let's read this my profession is being
demeaned by a pervasive atmosphere of
distrust dictating the teachers cannot
be permitted to develop and administer
their own quizzes and tests now titled
as generic assessments or grade their
own students examinations the
development of plans choice of lessons
and the materials to be employed are
increasingly expected to be common to
all teachers in a given subject this
approach not only strangles creativity
it's mothers the development of critical
thinking in our students and assumes a
one-size-fits-all mentality more
appropriate to the assembly line into
the classroom we have become
increasingly evaluation and not
knowledge-driven process has become our
most important product to twist a phrase
from corporate America which seems EE
appropriate to this case
okay let's stop there so so as you were
reading that so what are some of the top
of mind reactions you have um I
empathize with where he's coming from I
mean I could I could imagine being in
his position and and you know I don't
know exactly what he's reacting to he's
reacting very strongly to something it
sounds like someone's telling him what
to do essentially micromanaging him yeah
okay so let's so we just if I make some
notes somewhere around here I just
something about micromanagement I'd say
something about the strength maybe of
the of the other reaction so so what's
going on there the as you were looking
at that what in your own experience
either corroborates that or might cause
you to question that um you know I i
I've actually made video content with
with some folks that were that were very
particular about what I should cover in
what I what I don't cover and I think
for me a lot of the joy making videos is
my own kind of personal contribution to
it and and I and and I I personally do
react very strongly when someone kind of
shows me what what so I would circle
strangles creativity because that you're
clearly you're clearly emphasize
empathizing with your think it's right
right right not only strangles
creativity yeah it's Mother's the
development of critical thinking in our
student in our students now the
interesting question do you think that
by strangling your creativity I'm doing
a disservice to your students possibly I
essentially depends what this
one-size-fits-all curriculum that's
being pushed on to these teachers is is
doing but I could imagine that I mean
he's essentially complaining about two
things one some you know the state or
the district or whoever micromanaging
what he's doing but but he's also
complaining about the actual
micromanagement itself that it's
actually probably bad quality something
that he would fundamentally he's at he's
not thinking it's a great curriculum
that's being forced on it okay so
there's two interesting points that one
then is the system and the governance
right right and then this other one is
the actual execution of that governance
by people of low potentially or right be
a ver of low quality what about this
idea about becoming increasingly
evaluation and not knowledge-driven that
one III i agree i think they're too he's
he's reacting more against bad
assessments much less than the the
general idea of assessments in fact i
think if we have a conversation with
them i guess is that he wouldn't be anti
assessments of any kind it's just he's
anti bad assessments that are that are
trying to just kept her very superficial
understanding one-size-fits-all teach to
the test i hero right and he's to a
superficial test but but just to develop
you to talk about your point of view a
little bit you actually make quite an
important point of including testing in
the overall the corrective the overall
formation of your curriculum so why do
you do that why so there is an
evaluation part in there how is it
different from the evaluation he's
rebelling against I I mean even he also
clearly would like to write his own
tests and examinations I mean he
complains that he's not being allowed to
you know oh good point early on so I
don't think he's anti assessment you
have to somehow figure out whether the
students are kind of internalizing
what's what's going on in the classroom
I think I I think you know I probably
agree with him that it's really what the
assessment is about i mean i have seen a
lot of these kind of standardized
assessments that get put out at
especially the state level that really
are just measuring things in a very
superficial level versus versus deep
understanding okay I think that's great
and we might capture that something
about superficial now what we would be
doing if Sal was alone he'd be writing
notes on the page around it I'm kind of
distracting him a bit with conversation
but he'd be charged capturing his ideas
where he agrees maybe where he has a
slight departure let's try the next
paragraph stem rules the day we had last
damn rules the day and data-driven if
she can we tell people with stem stem
science technology engineering and
mathematics rules the day and
data-driven education seeks only
conformity standardization testing and a
zombie-like adherence to the shallow and
generic
in core dial underline along with a lot
lockstep of oversimplified so-called
essential learnings creativity academic
freedom teacher autonomy experimentation
and innovation are being stifled in a
misguided effort to fix what is not
broken in our system of public education
and particularly not at our school not
at our school I'm going to double
underline okay so how did you react to
this paragraph here I'm feeling a little
bit more mixed I mean I agree with them
stem to a large degree does rule the day
you know there's a huge focus on
mathematics and science and a lot
because that's where at least a
perception is a lot of kind of the
future jobs are where there's kind of a
word that we're falling short to a large
degree and arguably most of your first
1,000 videos were yes yes that's where I
figure I'm known for okay but I don't
think that's the most important thing
obviously we're doing other things right
now right right right this is not stem
feature data-driven education seeks only
conformity now I I know where he's
coming from and I understand his point
of view I I I don't think I don't think
he's saying I mean if I'm trying to
understand him I don't think he's saying
data-driven is bad I think he's all of
this when he's complaining about testing
and curriculum and data-driven he's
complaining about the variation of that
that's being imposed on him that's a
superficial data is kind of overpowering
other things which at which I would also
agree with although here you know it's
kind of data-driven being there started
to a 1-1 big bag yes you know the
opposite of data-driven is no data
driven it which is also not necessarily
a good thing i would argue there's some
name-calling going on in this paragraph
which which name calling is always a bit
day zombie like oh yeah this is
definitely got my attention let's look
like here's the shallow and generic yeah
here's a low and the generic common core
and this is actually interesting this is
another area where you know even at Khan
Academy were looking at the various
standards including the common core and
well we could go I could talk for hours
I'm sure and we could so but the point
about it is you're developing a point of
view where
while you empathize with his his
emotional reaction and you can see where
it came from your point of view is this
is not this is not a paragraph I think
you would have written restaurant how
would what would you have said about
stem instead that it's incredibly
important that it you know regardless of
whether you go into the stem field or
not it gives you analytical thinking
logical skills there's there actually is
a creative component to stem I mean you
know this is the Ian stem engineering
you know when you write a paper you're
kind of engineering I mean engineering
is fundamentally a creative pursuit yeah
it's like writing or painting or
anything else and so I think it's its
stem shouldn't be just thrown I think
sometimes those in those those in stem
sometimes the little the humanities as
saying oh it's just fufu you know
touchy-feely stuff that's not true it
teaches you critical thinking it makes
you creative etc etc and those that
sometimes in the humanities belittle to
them as I go it's its robotic it's
one-size-fits-all it's the right answer
versus the wrong answer there's no
creativity right and that's completely
false and right I'd argue that to be
great it's to be great in either it's
actually exercising the same muscles
great critical thinking great core
skills but a lot of creativity that's
what differentiates you in stem or the
humanities I think it's okay so that was
very cool by the way this might be a
place for us to kind of pull this into a
close we may not need to go after the
third paragraph so what I was doing with
Sal was essentially started with
somebody else's a letter and we the
first thing we tried to do was we tried
to capture the author's argument you saw
Sal empathizing with him kind of even
going the extra mile to give him the
benefit of the doubt you know this is
what he's saying but then at some point
he found his point of departure from
that and and ended up him saying a
pretty interesting thing about the
interaction between the humanities and
the stem curricula a little bit of right
brain left brain and how the to interact
with each other going forward that was
his point of view that was not anywhere
in this letter and the idea behind
invention when read and react is you
start with someone else's text you give
yourself over to the text you let the
other person's argument hold hold its
way so that you can understand it
but then at some point you diverge from
that argument you depart from it you
create your own point of view and in
academic writing that's what that's how
academics goes forward you you inherit
the tradition with what the what's been
written before you you read it you react
to it and then you contribute to it
going forward that's what what the read
and react invention process is for